[Music]
I remember Jason before we filmed season
two he said it opens and closes on
Nate's eyes and I was like oh what does
that mean
no at the end of season two there's a
bit of a Battleground forming between
Richmond and West Ham and that
Battleground is the pitch
what they did
um no one could have seen come in and it
feels like a huge betrayal I just felt
sorry for him like I was heartbroken for
him at the end of season two Ted was
always really good to him took him on
his wing like you know stepped him up he
made me feel like I was the most
important person in the whole world
and then
you abandoned me
lead the betrayer need the sun figure
out I think Ted was all those things I
think we're all those things it's a
really bold move by the writers to take
a character they deliberately got
everyone to root for and then just take
it away it's always good to keep people
on their toes in it well next season
should be fun right
[Music]
[Applause]
two months have passed since season two
and these characters are of shaking
everything up
regarding your old team AFC Richmond any
idea why everyone is expecting them to
finish 20th this season probably because
there's no 21st
we have to rebuild a family because the
family was broken if the team is a
metaphor for a society at large or a
family we wanted to see how this family
dealt with it did you hear what Nathan
was saying about you yes ma'am and are
you planning on addressing that no ma'am
I don't think Rebecca can quite believe
that of all the people that Nathan has
gone to it's effing Rupert there he is
the Wonder kid himself rather than
proving his Worth to the likes of Ted
who's obviously a Force for good he's
proving it to Rupert who's the force for
bad Lathan Shelley you are a killer
good morning
[Applause]
at the beginning Ted will feel a bit
beholden to a flippant promise he made
at the end of season one to win the
whole thing oh did I really say that yes
you did over there before you blasted
half a liter of Pellegrino in my face
all right wait what happened let's go I
think Ted has the opportunity this
season to make things better what would
you think we signed Zaba oh second
question who is Zaba
it's almost this once in a generation
footballer am I to assume that you're
going to pursue a notoriously Mercurial
player you can't afford simply because
your ex-husband wants him
love that people are going to see in
these characters the growth that they've
always wanted to see from season one
what are you doing I was gonna walk here
you came at me too fast it's really
interesting to watch the team grow
ultimately that's the story of tedlasso
isn't it you are it you are enough
expectations for US are as low as a
rattlesnake's belly button but hey we
got 38 chances to prove all them folks
wrong though right it will be as
fantastic as the show has been if not
more so how is it possible
sport is quite the metaphor
it also makes for a heck of a nickname
[Applause]